so hi everyone I don't know about you
guys but sometimes you sort of wake up
and you read the blogs and there's all
these fields and data science is amazing
but you do sometimes wonder like what's
the whole crowd doing and what what is
it that we're actually doing and it
turns out that there's these three
schools of doing things at least that's
when I look at things it seems to be the
obvious case there's this triangle on
one end you have these people that call
themselves for cuentas or that people
call for cuentas that's just the other
area that are filled with people that
call themselves bayesians and then you
have this other area where people call
themselves machine learning specialists
and even though we're doing similar
things or trying to do things with data
it seems like there's different things
happening and even though it seems that
it's very clear that if you're from here
you should be doing this it seems to be
a bit less clear that if you're here you
should consider this so that's sort of
the topic of my talk I'm gonna try to
convince you guys that if you're
thinking a little bit more along the
lines of this school of data you can
solve problems in a different and
sometimes better way and so there's a
whole lot of stuff I'm going to talk
about let's go ahead and talk about what
the textbook Bayes rule actually is in
essence the fact that there is this
thing called probability theory means
that if we just adhere to the rules of
math we didn't have to do any thinking
ourselves and Bayes rule is just a
summarization of that very simple
example I think I can assume that
everyone has seen this formula at least
once or twice I will not go over too
much in depth of it but I will give it
it is valid faith okay good set n is one
good but let's assume that I have a
situation where I'm rolling dice right
so here I'm rolling one die here I'm
rolling two dice here I'm rolling seven
and this I'm showing what the likelihood
is of the number of eyes that I am
rolling the cool thing about Bayes rule
is that I can then say given that this
is the number of dice that I've rolled
and this is the number of eyes that I'm
seeing however the trick is if I then
start to think about hey given that I
see this many eyes how likely is it that
I roll a certain dice instead of looking
at it from this way I can look at it
from this way and that's a very
convenient trick
so let's let's go over a very textbook
example and show some more cool things
you can do with this very very simple
rule so let's assume that there's an
epidemic it's a very scary disease and
we're worried about that a person has a
probability of 1 over 102 actually after
disease which is very high hence for the
authorities decide to test the
population like any test that is not
generally reliable and 1 out of 110
people will get a positive result but
given that you have to do sorry but
given that you have the disease the
probability of getting a positive result
is 65 over 100 so this should feel like
your first years college course in
probability theory and you can fill in
the numbers and you get this probability
out this so far shouldn't surprise
anyone so far so good we apply Bayes
rule we've learned some stuff it's kind
of neat we can infer more things though
and that's where the magic happens so
I'm assuming I've not lost anyone here
suppose that we can calculate all of
this so we can calculate the probability
that you have the disease given that you
took a certain test that's because we
know all of these things we're not
likely of getting a positive result in
tests likely of getting a disease and
the likelihood of getting a positive
test given that you had a disease but
also means that we can infer the fact
that the test came out positive if you
didn't have a disease that's because we
can split up the distribution
appropriately as well and you know if we
fill in all the numbers after some
calculation we get the number out so far
so good but sort of arbitrary why is
this interesting
well you can do this for getting to
positive tests you can do this for
getting three positive tests and again
you can argue this is interesting Vinson
but what's the point here this is just
arithmetic so far well the trick is the
situation where I take one test and have
to determine if you have the disease I
can now start to think about what it
might be like if you know if you took
two tests using all the inference we've
just done even though initially I only
knew about you know you tick that you
have the disease what's likely of
getting a positive test I can use that
knowledge to infer what the likelihoods
will will be if you have two positive
tests I can I do the same
if I take three tests well the math is
just there and I just have to follow
probability theory and what might not
seem as a very powerful thing at the
moment you will hopefully agree to
somewhat logical a powerful thing is
that suppose this is prediction time I
have a model and I have to predict
something I now have a model that can
accept different input at prediction
time most random forests don't work in a
way that if I have more data available
to me that then the prediction becomes
better I have to retrain the whole thing
so with this Bayesian mindset we seem to
be able to do some things that in the
machine learning land appear like it's
sort of voodoo so this is sort of cool
via Bayes rule we can infer information
about situations that we didn't
initially think about and the trick here
is that we clearly defined the
uncertainty that we have and we can
infer the rest by just applying
probability theory in this specific case
the main cheat was that we can realize
that the tests are independent of each
other
given that you have a certain disease
but the cool trick here is that we can
use the same model to have different
output a prediction time and still
adequately be able to manage everything
so this is a textbook example and you
can this is post on my blog with all the
numbers if you want to calculate it but
notice that we have this nice graph here
and we can sort of think about what that
graph might mean let's do that let's
talk about probably a graphical models
so we had a graph here which talks about
the structure of our system if you will
given this all of these things are
independent of one another so what do
those graphs in general look like and
I'm gonna use a very cool library called
Palmgren and it's fairly new and it does
some amazing magic for what I'm about to
do let's assume a certain situation I'm
not arguing that this is a very
realistic situation but let's say that
there are three broadcasters at a local
news station and they're all gonna be
predicting the weather these are weather
forecasters let's assume that alice is
great she's super accurate and let's
assume that Bob is terrible and let's
just shoot with Claire's already let's
then also assume that you know if I know
the person I know about how likely is
the weather
be predicted correctly but Letson also
assumed that depending on the weekday we
might know a little bit more about
whether alice is going to be predicting
or whether or not bob is going to be
predicting or whether that Claire is
going to be predicting and you should
notice that this sums up to one and
Letson also assume that given a day of
the week it might be a little bit more
sunny this oddly enough is not that
insane turns out there's places in the
world where on the weekends because
there's less cars about there's actually
less pollution and hence for if there's
more Sun it's the least ridiculous
assumption in the entire model anyway if
I were to then construct the logical
graph that comes out in a month I'm only
thinking about you know given this is
the resident independent this is what it
should look like it's a very simple
abite strange probabilistic graph not
strange because of the structure but
strange because of the example of X
picked now you can construct this in
library called Palmgren and this is sort
of the pseudocode of how you would do it
you would start at the beginning of the
tree so given this we should be able to
construct that so the first thing you
would have to construct in this tree is
the term D which is the day of the week
and yeah if there's a discrete
distribution available to you which you
can just use and there's also this
conditional probability table so the
idea would be given that it's a weekday
the probability of sorry the if you have
Alice it was very likely that was on a
weekday and you can fill these
conditional probability tables in with
the idea given this I can do something
about that and then given this I can say
something about that and you can
construct the entire tree you combine
them all together once you've defined
all the states you say how the states
are connected and you have this thing
called a network which you can at the
end tell it to bake itself there's this
syntactical detail but it's it's a
fairly clean IP I so definitely check
this library out later the cool thing
then is is I can ask the system then
suppose I know who did the predicting
what's the probability of the rest and
just like in the example we saw before
the amazing thing now becomes
this is a system if I put input in here
the rest is inferred and this is where
something freaky happens not only do I
now have a data system where if I only
know P I can infer the rest but I also
get the system whereas more data becomes
available to me the other variables
would become more accurately more
accurately predicted that is and that is
a very interesting system very few
neural networks do this but let's see
what the outcome of it all is if I say
it's Alice it turns out it's probably a
weekday we're very sure about who did
the predicting is it's the input of the
model we're also pretty sure it's
probably sunny and this is due to the
fact that it's probably inferred for the
day of the week and we also know
something about whether I was going to
predict it correctly and that's of
course because this is what we put into
the system itself it's the exact same
number we put in in the conditional
probability table the same thing for Bob
the probability that it will be
corrected sorry
predicted correctly is of course quite a
bit lower and here's situation where I
put two things in and obviously in this
small example these will be the exact
probabilities that I put into the system
but that's kind of the response at
Exeter expect so if the weather is
predicted correctly it's able to infer
that was most likely Alice but it could
have also been Bob and it could have
also been Claire
but the main interesting thing here is
hey at prediction time giving different
data sets this kind of system is able to
deal with it so these types of models
are very powerful and flexible and one
of those most powerful features is that
it can logically handle missing data at
prediction time so suppose for example
you might be a airline and you're not
exactly sure if this airplane is going
to come in on time or not but there's a
few things that you know and as time
moves on moves on more information is
known to you this might be a model
that's very useful because you have one
single system that you can ask many
different queries and again the example
I've given here just handles the street
models but math
the relationship is just defined can be
continuous as well coding these things
up is using the harder part pomegranate
currently only offers discrete
distributions not continuous once there
are sampling libraries that offer a form
of alternative but I am sort of more
hoping that we can get this pomegranate
library that's work with continuous
distributions as well yeah shout out to
the guy that made it I will also do a
unconference session with this library
sir if you're interested in hey how does
it work can we coat it with a bit five
o'clock that room will do a small demo
and explain it to you would also love it
if you guys maybe considered
contributing to this package because
it's I think it's gonna be the next
great thing in probabilistic programming
so these were examples wherever you had
a certain type of model where hey this
sort of comes from the bayesian world
this type of modeling is nice but it's
also the Bayesian thinking that
sometimes really shines I'm going to
share an example with you from from a
book from David McKay who unfortunately
passed away this week but I'm gonna
translate an example from this book to
hopefully an example that you guys can
imagine so let's assume I'm Dutch so I'm
from Amsterdam and in Holland I'm not
sure if you have them in England as well
we have these very small backyards with
these small walls and suppose that you
are like a true crazy data scientist
they're always collecting data you can
imagine that some at some point if
there's a very tall person you actually
see the tall person pass by and let's
assume that you're also deaf so you can
only see the people but you are aware of
the fact that only tall people pass
above the wall and henceforth what you
see the average length of people is
biased but you know how the data is
biased but you know that there's bias in
the data but you know that there is bias
because you're only measuring people
above a certain height the question I
would like to pose then is what can we
then say about the entire population so
we know that we've got biased data can
we say something in general about the
rest of the people and if you're say a
pure frequentist
this might be tricky whereas if you're a
Bayesian this is actually quite a lot
easier now I will give the example
differently because height is a bit of a
nasty example because
we kind of have to assume that people
are distributed normally so you probably
have like a an average and some
variation so let's think of a different
example but this is sort of the kind of
problem we're trying to tackle with this
way of thinking
so let's you know pick another very
realistic example suppose I have a call
center and suppose that we're interested
in knowing how long people wait in line
and let's suppose and this is a big
assumption but it's mainly meant to push
the example forward supposed to be only
measure people in the waiting line
who've been waiting for a very long time
let's say after seven and a half minutes
then they start to complain to the other
customer service and that's when we
start to measure them anyone who's been
waiting less than 7 or 1/2 minutes we
don't measure simply so what can I then
say about the waiting time in general I
only met you a few people and their
waiting times are biased let's say that
they're larger than some value M and I
know nothing else again I'm hoping that
you're aware for the problem is and that
you may realize that this indeed feels a
bit tricky so okay let's first then
think about how we're going to simulate
the waiting time usually one uses an
exponential model basically it means
that we have this variable called lambda
that's type of parameter of this
distribution and the idea is there's a
lot of people who wait for a very short
amount of time and there's some people
who wait for very long amount of time
but this is usually a very thin tails
and most of the density of the
distribution is around that corner but
for two different values of lambda this
is a higher value because it has a
thicker tail this is what the
distribution sort of looks like and
we're interested in finding out what
lambda is the appropriate one given that
we have biased data so gee how do we do
that mm-hmm tricky tricky there's lots
of sampling techniques I guess I could
go ahead and try but they kind of would
have a pure solution base to the rescue
suppose that we've biased data then this
is basically the metric we're interested
in and let's you know do the math a
given B and then just fill in formula
looks like this sure it's a continuous
distribution at times but this is what
it looks like so given a certain value
of lambda we should be able to say
something about the likelihood of how
the data got created well I think about
it you can make it a little bit sim
because let's assume that I'm just
optimizing this I'm only interested in
finding the max value for this but I'm
not as much interested in what this
probability is because it's just a
normalizer I'm more interested in what
the maximum argument for this would be
so I can drop the PD bias and let's make
it even simpler if I want to know the
likelihood of this bit and I have a data
set then basically I can use the law of
probability I'm assuming that there's
some form of Independence between these
numbers here
then I can say just multiply every
single data point and then you have a
combined likelihood and of course all of
this just follows from using this Bayes
rule trick which isn't really a trick
it's just a law of probability
okay so this seems like a genuine okay
way to go but we want this to work so
let's code it up with a couple of for
loops first it's alright to mention that
this of course is the distribution we
might be interested in giving a certain
lambda but we have to accommodate for
the fact that we have a certain M so we
only measure above a certain threshold
here let's say this one so then this
likelihood should be the likelihood of
this beautifully painted red bit that's
the distribution we're actually
interested in because we're interested
in when the data itself is biased so
this is a distribution we're actually
pulling from it's a distribution of
interest and this is the only hard bit
because the rest you can normalize the
distribution so suppose we have this bit
this bit has to integrate all out to one
so we have to normalize that that's what
I do here with a bit of math but I guess
instead of focusing on the math the
easiest way to do is just to write a
couple of functions and for loops so
let's assume that given a certain lambda
and given a certain value of M I just
have a small function that can calculate
the probability that X came from this
distribution and let's also do the same
thing for instead of having X is given
lambda let's also have one for a single
X again let's not focus on the code too
much because I can also use plot it
given different
the value isn't given the same em value
this is what different distributors
might look like and given the same
lambda value but different M values this
is what the other distributions look
like and the idea is if I measure a
certain point of data let's say this one
I had a data point at 10 and this is the
likelihood that's the likelihood and
that's a likelihood similarly here if I
had a data point coming in here that
would be a value for a likelihood that
would be a value and that will be a
value and I have a way now to given a
certain M compare different likelihoods
through from lambdas to actual
likelihood that I can multiply so I can
combine it all and given some data let's
say I measure these numbers and I have a
certain M and I'm going over different
lambdas and I can have different
distributions appear this is kind of
hypothetical so instead it might be best
to simulate our own data and confirm
that it actually works I think that
might be more appropriate so let's say
the true lambda is equal to 1 I have
this M that's equal to 6 I'm generating
a whole bunch of random exponential data
and then I only make a subset of it and
I only want to have the values that are
actually larger than M I'm going to do
this a bunch of times to show that this
algorithm actually works so let's say I
have a large subset for a very large
sample I take a subset and I only have
two values and remember the true value
of lambda was equal to 1 then what my
distribution says is well 1 is over here
it's not completely maxed out over there
the things that the true land that might
be a bit smaller but instead of giving
like one single estimate of the maximum
likelihood I now have a distribution of
a potential values of lambda might be so
instead of focusing on a single maximum
likelihood estimator my estimation
becomes more of a likelihood instead and
that's usually what basins do instead of
saying hey uncertain about my data but
I'm certain about my model evasions
prefer to say well I'm a little bit
uncertain about my model actually I'm
actually quite certain about the data so
this is if I have two points if I then
get more points you will notice that it
will actually start to converge and if I
get even more points you will notice it
actually gets there quite easily so what
happened here this is a basic summary we
started all over the problem it was kind
of tricky and yes we had to do a little
bit of math but the only math we really
had to do was to acknowledge that we had
a Bayes rule here and that we had
different distributions here which
needed some probability theory but it
did allow us to get this very nice model
out where if I get more data in I'm able
to update accordingly so it's kind of
fitting for more of a real-time purpose
so these are all data science topics and
that's fine
but I even found that Bayes rule can
help in different fields like feels like
autumn is Asian science so let's pick a
optimization problem that we know the
answer of beforehand and let's see if
probablistic thinking like Beijing's do
can even help us here so let's pick a
very silly example suppose I have a 1 by
1 square and I'm interested in finding
the largest triangle this is very easy
if you're a human because you just know
top middle and left and you can make a
triangle up here that's huge but if you
tell this to our algorithm it needs to
figure some stuff out so here's what I'm
doing I'm just gonna create random
points in the 1 by 1 square and I'm
gonna look at the area of the triangle
that's there that's what this shoelace
function does by the way and this is the
distribution of area given that I have
random points and one thing that you
should notice if we just take the random
approach we're actually sampling from
the area we're least interested in maybe
want to sample here because this is
where large triangles are but if we just
sample randomly we get the small
triangles out a little bit of math one
way of looking at it is to say ok I now
have a probability density distribution
of the area it's sort of the histogram
you've just seen that's fine instead how
about we've probably sick thinking we
turn it on its head so instead of saying
we're interested in the probability of
the area let's say we are only
interested in points where the area was
above a certain value
and once we've selected that subset I'm
interested in the distribution of X and
X being the location of the points and
to be very specific and exact let's say
that X is a vector of six variables X 1
X 2 X 3 y 1 y 2 y 2 y 3 so i sample all
this randomly i then have the histogram
a cut away to put the areas that are
small and then i look at what the next
distribution might look like for the x's
and this is very lovely library called
corner where you can just have a high
dimensional space and have it pull it
out for you that's what you see here so
this is 4 X 1 X 2 X 3 y 1 y 2 y 3 and
you already notice that I'm not only
doing a little bit of inference but it
is noticing how to do this correctly if
I want to have large triangles and will
be appropriate that the X 1 and X 2
values are far away from each other
because they're little triangles ought
to be a bit larger I think I can zoom in
on that yep so large triangles will be
far apart we're just sort of what you
see here if X 1 is small X 2 ought to be
big and vice versa and that's
interesting because if I look at x and y
combinations then you notice it's fine
if x and y are in one corner or if X is
smaller Y is big or they're both big or
they're not going to be anywhere in the
middle there's also a property of a
large triangle and the trick here was to
think again a little bit politically
about it what am i interested in well
I'm not really interested in the area
I'm more interested in the distribution
that generates triangles with a high
area so let's turn it into a learning
step then so if I have this histogram
how about it take the top half learn
from that get a new distribution to
sample from I think I use the kernel
density estimator from scikit-learn to
do this this was the original one and
let's do learning from it and then
sampling new points and then looking at
what the new area will be suddenly we're
sampling areas that are significantly
larger
and we can repeat and do it again so
again we would say you get the biggest
half sample from it again get the
biggest half shuttle from it again and I
think I did this three times and then I
add the biggest triangle so the idea is
to repeat this idea until we have some
form for convergence
know that M in this case can be chosen
automatically such that M is equal to
the average of the areas and the cool
bonus with these algorithms is that we
can use inference on our simulated data
to learn more about the nature of
optimization problem and you should
notice some form of similarity here with
genetic algorithms basically genetic
algorithms do one thing well let us do a
biased search that's what Bayes rule can
help us do here as well it's it's kind
of nice that we can get baseball in here
to even solve problems that typically
are not part of data science in this
next bit I will talk about how base we
will inspired me for some feature
engineering but I do want to double
check if everyone knows what I'm talking
about
does everyone know this game yes like
one vain guy in the back yes it's not
even a like a full-blown yes I played
this game but sort of yes I hate myself
that I play this game I've spent too out
too many hours playing this game as well
but I was just doing it for the data
science of it so there's this great
franchise it's called blizzard and they
make great games I mean the world of
warcraft was from them and they have
starcraft which is basically the same
but more pew-pew and the idea is that
there are two teams and you get to pick
characters and then the question is
which team will win and something that
seemed interesting to me at least was to
think about hey suppose that this team
selects that character that character
this character and that one and the
other one selects this one this one this
one and this one so you probably have
team space warrior for this team
swordsman or something but can we do
some inference and see who might win and
if you think about it it's actually kind
of hard so I only have some I have some
data if you go on Reddit and type in
here's of the storm match outcomes you
will find a guy who off the guy has a
service called hogs logs or something
where you can send your own video game
data and it tries to give you some
information Wow
improve your game in the meantime it
collects all of these game outcomes and
it tries to make this internal ranking
to help predict players who might win
but it also means that I have about half
a million games available to me so I
have some form of information about
which character choices might be good
but if I look at the search space so
let's say n is the number of heroes in
the game if I only have 20 heroes and I
think at the moment we have 40 if I only
have 20 heroes and even if I have half a
million games then there are more
allocations possible of heroes and I
actually have games in my data set so
any random forest will have a bit of
sparse the issue here and also if I
think about the data structure this
doesn't really fit well in a you know
standard tables you have team 1 heroes
which would be 40 row 40 columns and
then a couple of them will have ones and
the rest will be all zeros and at the
end it should say team 1 or team 2 so
already I'm having a bit of trouble
getting is to work in scikit-learn so I
actually when I will run this I will
expect a lot of machine learning to fail
this is something without running any
code I can already imagine happening we
have 72 columns out of which every row
will have only ten items filled in and I
think given the fact that we don't have
billions and billions of rows even
random forests and the neural Nets will
just not be able to get any pattern out
of it will mostly be true this noise so
instead of trying hard to create
features that might perform well in this
case because we might be able to extract
some manually let's see if we can use a
little bit of the main knowledge to help
us out for ballistic lee instead so this
is team b this is team a and whenever
i'm doing in the middle we need to have
some features that go to pee-pee is some
form of prediction algorithm and i want
to generate some form of features here
okay well one thing i could do is i
could say this is the first hero from
team a that's the first varial from Team
B let's just come do something with
combining them in a note here now let's
do it for every single hero and again
this should be sort of seen as a some
form of flowchart given this state
that state will be filled in and yeah if
I draw all the lines and becomes a
little bit hazy so let's instead
introduce a new notation people like to
call this plate notation the idea is for
every eye in team a and every J and team
B we have all these nodes in the middle
and they will all go to some form of
prediction algorithm let's keep it in
the middle what that it fiction other
isn't exactly is what I can then do is
suppose given this and given that I
could have some form of distribution
here namely given that team a fix
Muradin and team B fix Kerrigan I can
sort of get this beta distribution out
for what is the likelihood that team a
might win it's kind of like a a beat
test in that sense how likely does it
that this team will win or that team
will win given that I only know this and
I do that for every single hero
combination if you will and what you can
do you can make this pretty gif where
you generate all these distributions
you'll see about 25 of them and then
when there is 25 of them you'll see them
combined in this new distribution and
again this is this is what the feature
engineering bit would do and once you
see the black line that's what I would
call my predictor with what it would do
is it would take all of these
distributions and use probability theory
to combine them all back into one single
distribution and that distribution will
tell me how likely it is as I say guess
that one team will win from the other
team and be reminded if you're paying
attention you will notice gee all these
values are actually sort of around 50%
so is this model performing badly yes
and no you have to imagine that there's
a team if I think 40 people half of
which probably Korean who are doing
their best to optimize this game for
balance so if I'm able to find any
imbalance whatsoever that's already
something I could potentially sell to
Blizzard as a game improvement if I'm
able to gets a 1% chance out of this
that's already millions of games but
while I'm at it I mean this is this is
all right but there's let's just think
about properties here would this still
work
if for example I knew all the five
players from this team and maybe only
three players from this team well sure
I'd be drawing last sities but the whole
combining trick would still work and
it's actually robust as well I can have
some form of Pryor maybe if I don't have
any information about Team B so that's
kind of nice but maybe we can even
expand a bit further so how about
instead of just taking one hero from
Team A and one hero from Team B how
about we take two heroes from Team A and
two heroes from team B we would have a
lot more nodes in the middle if you will
and each node would have less data but
by the fact that I have a lot more nodes
I might be able to improve upon that
okay so that's kind of nice and even now
I have the the characteristic that if I
know say only four players from Team B
this whole model would still not break
like a normal network would and while
I'm at it how about we create these two
models next to each other there's some
form predictor that takes whatever comes
out of here as input and we then later
combine these two together and build a
huge ensemble of it or maybe even at the
end here have a neural network which
takes all this as input this Bayesian
convolution no it's just graphical
modeling but it has a lot of nice
properties so I actually went over this
quite fast little quicker than I
anticipated but I hope at least I have
convinced you that some of this Bayesian
thinking is something to be noted and
something where you can actually play a
lot with but to convince you guys of how
I at least experienced these three
schools let's do one more small example
and because whenever I talk about this
sort of thing you know you go to the
client the client has a classical
textbook statistics background and the
first thing the client will go is the
oldest Bayesian stuff is nice but I
don't see any confidence intervals or
p-values or statistical significance
tests and this feels all very different
how should I interpret this well kind of
come back to this triangle then and I
think this is the best way to summarize
it all models are wrong some models are
useful what are you most uncertain about
are you unsure about the data and are
you trying to fit the best single
estimator to summarize this this would
be sort of maximum likelihood regression
and let's say you're doing normal
regression you would probably then say
okay I have the maximum likelihood
estimator I'm gonna fit some sort of T
distribution on it and I'll see if it
deviates from zero by doing a t-test you
can also say well I'm unsure about my
model and I accept my data to be the
only ground truth in that sense the data
is the truth and will then say well I'm
not sure about my lambda but it's
probably in this region and have some
probability distribution which i think
is the best way to describe the
uncertainty that I have what you can
also do is you can say I'm not uncertain
at all because I have awesome test set
performance that's what machine learners
tend to do a little bit more of and to
give the most blunt example of it
because we're doing Python I'm sure we
like pandas this is an image from
matplotlib and there's an image of a
panda and what I then did I looked at
all the pixel values I believe then
black would be close to zero and white
would be close to one and I figured
let's ABC of different schools think
differently about this can i how can I
infer what a panda is it looking at this
and what I can do is if I'm a four
cuentas we get something that's
obviously a little bit weird I couldn't
then say what's my maximum likelihood
estimator well then it says the average
panda is indeed gray the thing that I
find scary though is that if you then
say okay let's look at the standard
deviation and the variance and plot that
over it you see that this model allows
for values that are smaller than zero
and larger than one to me that seems
rather unsensible so what and again this
is sort of my blunt translation of how I
think for Qantas think I'm sure there's
a sensible frequenters out there this is
what a Bayesian I guess will do more as
a Bayesian would say I'm not going to
summarize all of the pixels together I'm
just going to talk about the uncertainty
that I have for each individual pixel
and then something which I find sensible
comes out it's not super likely the
Panda is gray but it's probably a little
bit more black and white this pattern is
particularly is a little bit more white
which is the case a machine learners of
course would go I don't know what a
panda is but my test set suggests that I
have this amazing performance so in
general I always find that if I'm gonna
be anywhere I'll probably be around this
corner this feels very comfortable to me
and also if I think about what's new my
most excitement is I feel very
comfortable being here and deep neural
network what's the Bayesian
interpretation of this I like working on
I tend to dig take these people a little
bit less seriously but in all honesty
and I also sometimes use some things
from that school if I do a regression
for the first time I kind of like the
fact that I can interpret the T
statistics to say whether or not a
certain type of column can be taken out
or not if you're going home with
anything please just remember never let
your school it get in the way in your
education and more specifically give
this area to triangle a chance I mean
there's there's freaky stuff out there
which might feel is voodoo but stuff
that's actually based on common sense
because it's all just probability theory
that's what I got
oh and and before people start a rant
yeah I'm making fun of this obviously
but this is of course sensible right no
but you know honestly I'm making a bit
of a fool out of this but it is in some
way sensible that if you don't know
exactly what you're doing because it's a
huge black box but it performs well and
keeps on performing well always and that
you might still have a sensible model
I'm not saying you should completely
ignore this however with this example
the only thing I do hope to point out is
that there are some preferable aspects
to modeling things this way questions
sorry this sounds like a blasphemy from
what I understand which is I mean I
didn't know much before they say well no
one's going of this picture is that it
tells you more so it's a bit if I ask
you one number you lose part of the
advantage but the point is why couldn't
I talk about statistical significance
from a plot of from the result of by
Asian so immediately you have pointed
out to some of the weakness at this
point I am purposely chosen this example
such that I can say hey if you're taking
a very very classical thinking it
doesn't apply to this one example that's
not to say that it will fail for every
single example I'm just using this point
here that in this case I'm making fun of
both the four cuentas and the machine
learners here to point out that Bayesian
sometimes actually have a very nice way
of thinking about things that's not to
say usually for a lot of problems if you
were gonna say yes or no in terms of
significance both of these two schools
would overlap in their opinion but there
are these slight little differences and
this is the best one I could come up
with as an example hi thank you for the
talk first of all I have a question
about in the example that you showed
about the weighting of the clients
whether one yeah yeah
people said income paying up to seven
and a half minutes
all the way back this one yeah yep
so in a new model you went quickly on
the assumption of conditional
independence and I'm guessing it's
because numerically when you do high
dimensional integration it becomes very
intractable so because I've never used
it in practice oh do you always in
practice when you when you when you go
for a Bayesian approach do you always go
for conditional independence so that you
can but the the subject is you're
touching is the exact weakness of this
type of modeling so this is very easy if
I know the structure of the tree here
right and this is the assumption right I
know something about the conditional
independence what you could also do is
you could say I don't know the structure
let's try and learn that you usually get
into your ristic country when you do
that and there's no guarantee of
optimality so to get this to be very
tractable I am making these assumptions
and what I'm hoping is that as a sort of
domain expert that this tree that I have
generated is sensible but you are fair
in saying that that's a bit of an
assumption it's certainly the case so in
practice people always make that
assumption
yeah but then again any model does even
random forests have some form of
assumption namely that you can make so
many trees and that that's logical
thinking but again all models are wrong
some of them are useful if you're
interested in this by the way I'm gonna
give a small demo I'd love to hear some
feedback yep okay final question could
you recommend any resources for a non
mathematician I do have some advice
there is this amazing blog that I write
but now and the there's a tutorial on
how I did the inference thing with a
little bit of math just a little bit of
it I found that it was trending on data
tile at some point so I guess some
people will like the stuff that I write
about it if not that there's a couple of
books which are a little bit Matthew but
not too mathy and those are the three
books I recommend to any data scientist
there's
Bayesian learning and machine learning
by Barbour there is information theory
and neural networks I think the books
called from David McKay
it's the reference I made earlier and
there's machine learning from Bishop and
the cool thing about those books is they
all start with there's probability
theory and this is Bayesian thinking and
only then do they talk about machine
learning and even then they try to stick
some Bayesian thoughts into how they
coincide there I think blogs and those
couple of books would be your best bet
that's how I got started
thank you we return it's 3:30 for the
final decision please Bank Vincent for
his page - oh wait wait wait I want to
do one joke so the the Bayesian goes to
the frequentist and says oh you're very
average and the Bayesian says no you're
mean